Republicans are blowing it they're
completely blowing it the media have
more or less admitted that the lock
downs are bogus BS how do we know they
did that because they told this was the
most important thing to lock down then
for two or three weeks they said run
wild loot riot protests go to a Pride
Parade go to a BLM rally it's good
that's actually going to help stop the
spread of kovat then the minute all that
is over they tell us that we need to
lock down to get closed restaurants not
go to work we know that that is BS we
have seen politicians telling us we have
to wear masks even as they themselves
are not wearing masks even the exalted
doctor foul Qi peace be upon him the
great lab coated Overlord that no one
elected even doctor foul she was caught
on video taking his mask down end of a
meeting
cameras are theoretically off he pulls
his mask down below his chin they're
looking around that's exactly how I wear
my my mask when I am traveling or when
they make me wear one in a restaurant or
something like that
there was another video foul she was on
a cell phone and he's having this call
that he looks over he sees there's a
camera pulls the mask right back up
they're showing it to us folks it does
not matter it's they've changed their
mind a million times and yet every time
they go for the lockdown every time they
go for these measures it seems
convenient to Democrats we talked
yesterday about how the lockdown is the
Joe Biden campaign will guess what
Republicans are falling for it again
they're going right along with it
with Republicans like this who needs
Democrats
I'm Michael Knowles and this is the
Michael Nolt show
[Music]
if the Democrats weren't the Democrats I
don't think I could be a Republican
that's how frustrated I am with the
Republican Party today we will get to
specific Republican senators who are
driving me up a wall but first I want to
get to the question I asked yesterday
which is the VP race is heating up who
do you think sleepy Joe will be told to
pick as his running mate in my favorite
response to this is that Aunt Jemima is
leaving the serie bottle to be Joe
Biden's running mate makes perfect sense
to me I also want to thank our friends
over at Blake's ale links ale is the
revolutionary invoicing software that is
changing the landscape for small
businesses and independent contractors
everywhere you should not have to send
nagging emails to get your invoices paid
with bling sale you can send beautiful
custom branded invoices and estimates in
seconds you can stay on top of your
outstanding invoices you can elect
customers and clients easily pay your
invoices online and you will get instant
notifications when a customer opens your
invoice so that you will actually know
if they're just trying to avoid paying
which sometimes happens forget about
using those invoice templates or
stressing about coordinating a bunch of
different software programs or putting
something together in a word processor
or something like that don't do that I
have freelance before I guess I still
technically freelance I never stay on
top of those invoices blink sale makes
it so so easy you can see for yourself
try it blink sale for free at blink sale
comm slash Knowles that's bli NK s al
EECOM / Knowles blink sale spend less
time billing and more time doing what
you love
so we're shutting down again we're gonna
pretend that the last three weeks of
rioting and protests never happened la
is doing it la is Mayor Eric Garcetti
tweets out quote kovat has taken control
and we need to take control back that's
what we did in March April and May when
we sacrificed stayed safer at home and
saved lives we need that same commitment
to flatten the curve now notice he takes
that June which is when they let up on
everything and allowed roving bands of
leftist rioters to burn down the country
that that was cold but now we got to go
back but by the way the spike the super
spike in the co vid cases has
nothing to do with the leftist riots
nothing to do at all pay no attention to
the man behind the curtain we were the
first major city to require face
coverings he writes and we must continue
to wear them gathering with anybody
except for those you live with may
spread the virus and that's why more
businesses and places where people
gathering doors are closing or must
operate differently and he's announcing
this right before 4th of July weekend to
punish people to make people feel like
things are terrible and to to drive us
all absolutely mad we didn't get this
tweet when they were out there
protesting for any of the various social
justice left causes I think he said one
thing here that's true we need to take
control back we need to take control
back from demagogue leftist hacks who
are exploiting some kind of sickness at
this point now 100 percent politically
and they're going to do it until
November 3rd we need to take control
back from them well who could lead us to
take control back from these Democrats
Republicans could lead us but they're
not they're not doing it they are
rolling over which is basically the only
thing they ever know how to do we know
that it's not just la closing down again
Texas the great state of Texas is
locking down again Republican governor
there I don't know they're just they're
going along with it they don't want the
mean articles in the New York Times they
don't want to withstand the the attacks
from the left that are obviously going
to keep ramping up for November 3rd
Texas is locking down again with one
exception and that would be vanilla ice
yes there are many things that are
surprising one vanilla ice is still
performing all those years all those
decades after Ice Ice Baby
but Vanilla Ice gets a pass why because
the the concert venue that he's going to
be performing in is the islands two or
three thousand seat place but it's
primarily a restaurant so they've and
even though the bars and everything
we're closing down somehow there is a
loophole here and vanilla ice gets to
continue to perform and the saddest
part of all of this is that vanilla ice
has a better understanding of politics
and medicine than most elected
Republicans and certainly than the
governor of his state that's it's weep
for your country folks when Vanilla Ice
understands more about politics than
your elected leaders Democrats
understand a lot about politics and I
think they understand about medicine - I
think they're lying for political ends
and I think they are lying shamelessly
and the the double standard and the
hypocrisy is so transparent but they do
understand that they know what they're
doing it's the Republicans that are
driving me so crazy here because they
are just allowing the Democrats to do it
consider this everything that we have
seen from a political standpoint in the
last three months is almost created in a
laboratory I don't know about a
laboratory in wuhan but a laboratory in
some political scientists basement to
help Joe Biden and to hurt Donald Trump
you know Joe Biden's gonna try to get
out of the debates or make the debates
more of a virtual kind of thing that
will give him a benefit they have a
candidate who can't campaign so what
they do they cancel the campaign they
have an opponent an incumbent president
Donald Trump who holds these massive
great rallies so what do they do cancel
the rallies they have a candidate who
makes a lot of gaffes right he just if
Joe Biden were on the campaign trail
right now he'd be making ten gaffes a
day at least so what do they do they
lock him in a basement they had an
incumbent with the best economy in the
history of the world what do they do
crash the economy and then when we
flatten the curve we do everything they
say for the medical science there's
there is no more medical or scientific
argument they can make what do they do
they say yeah we're gonna do it again
anyway
why not because you're not gonna stop as
Republicans cuz you're a bunch of
dummies and I'm sad to say Republicans
are the the move from a Republican
senator that set me off and it just made
me realize yesterday that they don't
understand anything was actually not
related to CO vid necessarily it wasn't
directly related to black lives matter
something like that though it was
indirectly related to that two
Republican senators Ron Johnson
and james lankford moved to cancel
Columbus Day two Republican senators I
expect that of Democratic senators I
expect that of blue haired leftists on
college campuses I don't expect that of
my Republican senators what was the
argument well the argument here this is
from Ron Johnson Republican from
Wisconsin in response to a bipartisan
effort to give federal workers another
day of paid leave yeah because that's
what federal workers need is another day
of paid leave by designating Juneteenth
a federal holiday we have offered a
counterproposal that does not put us
further into debt like everything about
this is wrong every so that here's the
here's the point they want to make
Juneteenth a federal holiday get to
Juneteenth in a second but they don't
want to run up any more debt they don't
want to have to pay any more money for
that now these these hoi polloi workers
that they they were they don't work
enough as it is and if we're actually
talking about federal government workers
that's true but even even extrapolate
this out and talk about workers all over
the country they're saying well we don't
we don't want people to get like free
money or a free day off but we do want a
virtue signal to the left
woke racial identity politics mob so the
way that we're going to designate
Juneteenth a federal holiday is that
we're going to cancel Columbus Day I
look forward to donating to the primary
campaigns of anyone who will run against
Ron Johnson and James Lankford as a
Republican although at this point I'm
kind of souring on these Republicans
because they don't get it first of all
Juneteenth should not be a federal
holiday
Juneteenth should not be a federal
holiday because it's not a national
holiday
what is Juneteenth I would say the vast
majority of people had never heard about
Juneteenth until leftist political
activists started to talk about it at
nauseam a couple of weeks ago but I
think and then everyone tried to pretend
like there Eddie knew about it but I
think if you were being honest with
yourself you would for most people say
they didn't know what it is what is
Juneteenth Juneteenth is the day that
the Union Army announced in Texas the
emancipation of the slaves it's not the
day the slaves were emancipated by the
Emancipation Proclamation
not the day that the 13th amendment
freeing the slaves went into effect not
the day the 14th amendment went into
effect just the day that the slaves were
told about emancipation in Texas which
by the way they'd already knew about
because there were other means of
communication than Union generals
rolling in and giving a public
announcement was it the first time that
the slaves were freed or that any slaves
were told of their freedom no was it the
last time was it the completion of the
emancipation of the slaves no two more
states were later told of their
emancipation Juneteenth as it is
observed is observed in relatively few
places in the country it is not a
national holiday if they were to make a
national holiday about emancipation they
would pick a different day because there
were national announcements about
emancipation but it isn't that the left
just picked it they just picked this one
and then they tried to guilt everyone in
the country into an interesting this is
the most important holiday cancel
Washington's birthday cancel Christmas
for goodness sakes this has got to be
the most important one they just picked
it at random there are other days the
Emancipation Proclamation would make
more sense frankly or any of them but
it's not about it's not about Juneteenth
it's not about another holiday as even
the Republicans here made clear it's
about taking away something it's about
taking away Columbus Day it's about
reminding America of the sin the
original sin of slavery they never want
to talk about the original sin of
original sin but in another day to
remember slavery well we of course we
remember slavery in the United States in
fact one of the effects of having
Confederate statues up is to remember
that slavery was a big problem such a
big problem we had debates over it at
the founding of the country at the
writing of the Declaration of
Independence at the writing of the
Constitution and then we fought a bloody
civil war where 700,000 Americans died
to fight over slavery we don't even I
don't think we need to be reminded of
that I think we remember that I think we
know that very well but this is about
tearing down something that goes even
further back
the discovery of the new world without
which none of us would be here some
Republicans have told me oh Michael this
is so frivolous wife oh that one
Republican commentator actually tweeted
at me and said why focus on something so
frivolous history and culture are not
frivolous and the dismissal of history
and culture as frivolous and the
redefining of the great conservative
tradition into nothing but tax cuts and
license is precisely what got us to the
last three weeks in the first place the
mayhem and the madness these guys Ron
Johnson and James Langford I hope they
withdraw their stupid stupid bill and I
hope that then I don't have to donate to
their primary opponents but they it's
just they typify perfectly exemplify
perfectly how Republicans just don't
freaking get it they don't get the
radicalism we're up against you know I
actually had the privilege of asking a
question of Karen bass here and bass is
a California congressman
Karen bass is the head of the
Congressional Black Caucus and Karen
bass is being strongly considered to be
Joe Biden's running mate
now no one's asking her tough questions
obviously so I was offered the
opportunity by Alex Michaelson who's an
anchor at Fox in LA to come on and ask
Karen bass any question I wanted so I
asked her a question about her troubling
support for Marxists she works very
closely with and supports the black
lives matter movement which we've talked
about on this show the leaders of BLM
refer to themselves as trained Marxists
one of them took a photo with the
communist dictator of Venezuela and
congresswoman bass herself has expressed
support for Fidel Castro praised Fidel
Castro when he died so my question to
her with that context was very simple I
said I said representative bass are you
willing to disavow Marxists and if you
are assuming that you are why do you
continue to support self-described
marxists here's her answer that's very
interesting because I've known
blacklivesmatter
individuals for quite a while and I have
never known of black lives matter to be
a Marxist organization you know one of
the challenges with organizing today
that's very different when I was coming
up is that we did have more solid
organizations whereas now you can have
people who are affiliated with a lot of
different different groups so that's a
black lives matter chapter that I'm
surely not aware of
oh she's surely not aware of that black
lives matter chapter except it's not a
chapter it's the national leadership and
I have proof that she is aware of them
here is patrisse cullors
one of the cofounders of black lives
matter describing both she and you're
describing herself and her co-founder
Alicia Garza as trained Marxists I think
that the criticism is helpful I also
think that it might I think of a lot of
things the first thing I think is that
we actually do have an ideological frame
myself and Alicia in particular trained
organizers we are trained Marxists we
are super versed on sort of ideological
theories of course we know they're
versed on this ideological theory of
Marxism anybody who reads the about Us
section of the website of BLM would
would know that I mean they use the word
comrades a lot they want to abolish the
police and they want to abolish the
quote Western proscribed nuclear
families so it's very strange to me that
Karen bass who works with BLM wouldn't
know the national leaders and wouldn't
have heard this very now viral clip of
them openly describing themselves as
trained Marxists so I did like two
seconds of googling and I found out wait
a second
Karen bass actually does know them
there's a photo of Karen bass speaking
with patrisse cullors in Congress and
then congresswoman bass tweets out
afterward thank you to Alicia Garza and
Patrice colores for joining the black
caucus for a forum on police brutality
this morning Congress needs to act so
not only did she have this conversation
in Congress on the record she later
tweeted about it so so this idea that
she doesn't know them is a flat-out lie
after she lied
Alex Michelson the anchor of the program
pushed her on the question of her
support for Fidel Castro and she ducked
that one too if I had to do it over
again I probably would have deleted that
if it offended people but again
promoting the relations between our two
countries I would never do that over
again she would probably not use that
phrase if it offended people if it
offended people this is a non-apology
apology this is sorry I'm not sorry she
doesn't regret supporting this Fidel
Castro's evil ideology she doesn't
regret supporting his brutality she
regrets it if it offends people my
question was will you disavow Marxism
she wouldn't she didn't she denied the
premise and she lied then she deflected
and she never did
why didn't she because she's not of
course she's not willing to disavow
Marxism compare this to the way that
Trump is treated Trump every single day
still disavowed white supremacy because
I disavow yeah but do you really disavow
it again okay i disavow white supremacy
it's terrible remember charlottesville
where he allegedly called white
supremacists and neo-nazis very fine
people remember in the exact same breath
when you talked about how they were
finding people on both sides of the
monument issue he said I'm not talking
about the neo-nazis and the white
supremacists who should be condemned
totally remember how multiple multiple
times during the campaign this is why
won't you condemn David Duke he says I
condemn David Duke I don't know David
Duke sure I condemn my disavow doesn't
matter it's never enough and yet this
woman seriously being considered for Joe
Biden's running mate he's asked a simple
question do you disavow Marxism after
all the support you've shown for it over
the years repeatedly and continually she
refuses to do it
that is a double standard but she's not
gonna be pushed on it at this
point the Crips gang understands the
political moment we are in better than
the Republican Party there is a video
going around of black lives matter
rioters sorry peaceful protesters coming
into Long Beach California not so far
from where I live and the I don't
they've run roughshod through all these
neighborhoods smashed windows you know
torched the whole neighborhoods well
they made it down to Long Beach and the
Crips a very well known well-established
gang here decided they weren't gonna
take that at all take a listen
she got this [ __ ] walking up to the BLM
guys BLM guys walking away thank you sir
say something it's obviously BLM went a
little weak because this [ __ ] guy looks
pretty big and pretty scary
and so the BLM guys walking away okay
yeah thank you thank you sir and this
BLM guys not having to say something say
something
the Crips now have a greater respect for
law and order not just then the peaceful
rioters but then our elected officials
certainly than the Democrats and
apparently the Republicans if the
Republicans are willing to indulge these
rioters very often willing to indulge
these lawless Democratic tactics and the
Crips are not
I mean if effectively these Crips have
become like the the cops and they're you
know the actual cops are told to stand
down and they got to be defunded and
they're not allowed to do anything so
now we're relying on gang law and it's
the best thing we've got in Long Beach
now apparently not a good State for the
country we wouldn't be in that situation
if one side simply stood up and said no
understood the political games that were
being played but that is not happening
and it's a you know we see this in
politics we see this in the perversion
of medical science and of course we see
this in the mainstream media so there
was this great image that came out the
other day of what I think should be the
new cover of the Brooks Brothers catalog
of Ken these called Ken and Karen that
gun couple the guys were in the pink
polo shirt and the chinos he's holding
his ar-15 and Karen is holding that
little tiny James Bond gun they're kind
of swinging the guns all over not great
trigger discipline so this guy the they
call him Ken the guy who's wearing the
pink polo with the gun he goes on Chris
Cuomo's show on CNN and Chris Cuomo
has a narrative in mind Chris Cuomo
hates that this couple defended
themselves Chris Cuomo loves that the
rioters are running roughshod all over
the country and so he directed his ire
at the the man who defended himself guy
stands in front of me pulls out two
loaded pistol magazine snaps them
together in front of my face and says
you're next okay if you were there Chris
I think you'd feel like you had a right
to defend yourself as well absolutely
somebody takes out magazines or
ammunition and clicks it and makes a
direct threat to me I would feel
threatened a hundred percent and that's
what happened to me and look I know that
you're going through a process with this
I welcome you having counsel if you were
within your rights to do what you were
doing it should be a judged as such I
wanted to talk to you about the broader
implication because it's just a horrible
picture of what's going on in America
right now so to me it's not about what's
right and what's wrong just in a court
of law it's about what we want right to
right and wrong about how we treat each
other and that's why the president is
tweet mr. Watkins you know it and mr.
McClosky
you know it he retweeted it because he
liked the image of white resistance to
this movement what what how on earth is
that your conclusion from roving gang of
thugs destroying your property
trespassing on your property and a guy
defends himself after another guy walks
up with magazines and starts clicking
them together and saying you're next
obviously threatening his life what
Chris Cuomo did is the thing the left
always does when they're stupid fake
propaganda narratives get disproven as
you said okay fine
right in the particular you're right
about what actually happened but even
though you were right about that and I
was completely wrong about that what I'm
talking about is a greater truth
oh yes the greater truth that is
completely disconnected from the actual
truth and the greater truth here mr.
McClosky
is that your white supremacist is so is
Donald Trump and the peaceful protesters
were totally peaceful and yeah I don't
know what happened to your wrought iron
gate but it certainly wasn't those
peaceful protestors that ripped it apart
no and they would never have have thrown
weapons in front of your face no and
they wouldn't have trespassed on your
property no no the greater truth is that
Donald Trump is an orange man who is bad
and I guess a white man also because
he's in the Ku Klux Klan and you're a
pawn in that so sorry about that
thankfully I'm so glad this guy
McCloskey stood up for himself and he
asked he esta Chris where on earth he
was getting that from his his Chris
Cuomo a mind reader and I'm not saying
that was fair to you but we know that's
why I did it because that's why he
deleted it
I wanted you to graduate I'm glad you're
a mind reader because no one else thinks
you are Oh
in fact he didn't delete it good makes
my point even know you didn't say that
it was said to me for me I'm thinking
about something else where someone was
screaming white power in a video that
the president retweeted he deleted that
one
he didn't delete the one of you I wanted
to give you a chance to speak about it
we both know you don't have to be a mind
reader to assess a pattern you're not a
mind reader either I haven't seen the
video of the person clap in the
magazines but you drew certain
inferences from the baver before you I'm
doing the same thing we've seen behavior
before us I'm making a judgement oh my
gosh this is so pathetic Chris Cuomo was
wrong in the particular then he was
wrong in his greater truth bs narrative
then he was wrong about the tweet which
was the point he was trying to make he
said the president retweeted this that's
why he deleted it I love McCluskey's
Lionel I'm glad you're you think you're
a mind reader Chris cuz no one else
thinks you are obviously not and he goes
oh no wait he didn't retweet it sorry I
got that part wrong too
okay so every single thing that I've
been saying for the last three minutes
is complete BS but anyway I think I'm
writing and you think you're right so
let's agree to disagree
do you see what
he said okay well mr. McClosky look some
guy was waving a gun in your face and
threatening your life and your family's
life and trespassing and destroying your
property so look but you're not a
mind-reader you don't know what they
were actually gonna do I mean they told
you what they were gonna do and you saw
them doing it and it actually happened
but you're not a mind-reader you drew
certain inferences and I chris cuomo
have an imagination so i invented
completely fictitious stories so you
know it's kind of the same thing Chris
Cuomo obviously a joke but he said
something that is not true it's
perfectly wrong but it does give you a
fundamental basic insight into the
leftist worldview he gave you beyond the
political issue in the BLM and the riots
and the kovat and the taxes and whatever
he gave you the theological the
religious basis of the leftist worldview
in about 10 seconds if you do the right
thing for yourself and your community
things will get better in this country
you don't need help from above it's
within us there it is that's
progressivism that is progressivism if
you come together and use politics in
your community
we will perfect human nature we will
have a utopia on earth well if as long
as we have the right policies and a
little more power and a little more
money we'll be able to fix all the
problems in the world you don't need God
you can be perfect you can be perfect
with our ideology that is the lie that
has been told to us by leftist
politicians by leftist intellectuals
going back at least to Karl Marx and
actually further back than Karl Marx
it's the lie that was told to us in the
Garden of Eden and it simply is not true
and people who have tried to effect a
politics this way have learned the hard
way that it's not true with a lot of
human misery in the meantime there is
not a political solution to everything
to the problem of evil to the problem of
pain to the problem of injustice lurking
in people's hearts there is not a final
perfect political solution to that you
do
need God every wise person in all of
human history has acknowledged that and
Chris Cuomo has not which I suppose
should be unsurprising to us the lack of
self-awareness here the hubris is
stunning I'll give you a great example
of this you know president rump is gonna
give a speech at Mount Rushmore and the
left oh man they hate this speech they
hate this speech they hate Mount
Rushmore
we joked a few weeks ago he said the
probably gonna try to cancel Mount
Rushmore they are they're trying to get
rid of Mount Rushmore now the New York
Times has this piece out how Mount
Rushmore became Mount Rushmore sounds
kind of like a modest piece right but
here's the tweet that they sent out with
it Mount Rushmore was built on land that
belonged to the Lakota tribe and
sculpted by a man who had strong bonds
with the Ku Klux Klan it features the
faces of two US presidents who were
slaveholders all right blow it up get
the Taliban in here blow it up whatever
you remember what they did to that
Buddha in Syria yeah well bring them in
here and around Afghanistan or wherever
wherever it was yeah bring them in here
and blow it up I don't know if where
they were in the Middle East but we need
to ship them to South Dakota now I'd
like to show the New York Times maybe
why it's not so great to go down this
road of trying to blow everything up for
past grievances the New York Times the
people who published this article in
that tweet this article was published by
a newspaper that denied the Holodomor
mass famine for Stalin that's a bad
thing covering up for Stalin the the
wickedest dictator in the 20th century
certainly up there certainly in the big
at the big two big three that's bad
that's worse than what any of the other
people did why are we permitting the New
York Times to exist but they want to get
rid of Mount Rushmore because it has
absolutely nothing to do with principles
nothing to do with rational argument
nothing to do with oh look we just want
to be heard we won't have a listening
session we just want one more federal
holiday and a yeah by the way we want to
cancel Christopher Columbus and tear
down his statues and we just look it's
it's reasonable it's
not reasonable there's no argument here
guys and these Republicans continue to
fall for it stop falling for it the
reason that we have a Republican Party
is to fight back against the Democrats
if they're not going to do that then we
need something else we need another
party and there's there's really no
point you saw this with the judges they
say you've got to elect Republicans for
the judges don't forget the judge well
you know if the judges aren't gonna do
anything if all the judges are gonna do
is roll over then give me the Democrats
at least they're honest all right at
least they don't relieve themselves on
my leg and tell me it's raining they
tell me exactly what they're doing
get your act together Republicans and
get serious and stop trying to get nice
comments about yourself in the new york
times which i think as you can tell if
they're not gonna be nice to george
washington they're not gonna be nice to
you and they're a totally corrupt
morally bankrupt institution that does
not deserve our admiration or respect
alright we'll get into the mailbag first
though want to thank you for subscribing
to the Michael Dahl show YouTube channel
I think we are up now past hundred
twenty thousand subscribers that was
very very fun you know I'm going to be
speaking to to my friend Dave Rubin
today so we're gonna get that interview
up over the weekend be a lot of fun bad
news is pod saves America is still
beating me on the amplified cast charts
just by a little bit but still if you
wouldn't mind heading on over there
subscribing leave a five star review
would very much appreciate it and by the
way if you're looking for something to
read over the weekend a little beach
read for those of you who don't have
tyrannical governor's who are keeping
you off the beach you should go by Ben's
new book how to destroy America in three
easy steps
obviously Ansel culture is it's around
us we're living in it right now and Ben
I guess he saw this coming and he wrote
this terrific book about it called how
to destroy America in three easy steps
you can pre-order your copy right now
daily water calm slash Ben Barnes Noble
or Amazon and you will get the full
picture of this strange moment in
history in Ben's inimitable prose a
really fun great great read for the
weekend sign up for daily wire readers
pass to 99 cents for your first month
three bucks a month after that daily
wire.com slash subscribe we will be back
with the mailbag
all right let's get into the mailbag I
always run late on the mailbag so I'm
gonna try to run through these as
quickly as I possibly can from Christy
Michael some of us in the Daily wire
autonomous zone or do as have a question
for the wordsmith of The Daily wire why
do Americans call our upcoming holiday
the 4th of July
instead of Independence Day we don't
call Christmas the 25th of December
after all is there a deep meaning or is
it that we are just too lazy to learn
how to spell the word independence
thanks that's a guy guess that's a good
suggestion as to why it is the simple
answer is I don't know why but it's not
it's not necessarily some nefarious
issue here I mean we do refer to other
days by numbers or sort of vague or
descriptions like we don't call the Ides
of March murder Caesar day you know we
can call it the Ides of March and you
know there there are other days that are
not referred to specifically by what has
what what they connote you know what
they what they bring about I like the
fourth of July as the title actually
prefer to say the 4th of July to
Independence Day because I like the idea
of claiming the entire day in a self
expressive manner to be about us to be
about the political founding of our
country I like the idea that when you
say the 4th of July it could only mean
one thing and that could mean American
independence so I refer to it that way
but I'm sure eventually not only is the
life is going to cancel the word the
phrase Independence Day they're going to
cancel the number-four they're gonna
cancel the month of July because it
sends such shivers up and down their
spine from Chris Michael I am lead
counsel in a lawsuit we filed against
mayor Bowser in DC for constructing the
black lives matter banner on 16th Street
we're making the argument that black
lives matter is a denominational sect
that is inseparably linked to the
religion of secular humanism do you
agree the Supreme Court beginning in
torque aza versus Watkins found that
secular humanism is a religion that is a
terrifically clever lawsuit I really
like that
i I'm sorry to say I'm skeptical or
doubtful that you will be successful I
don't think the courts are going to go
there but certainly it is the case black
lives matter does have a strongly
religious aspect to it I mean just just
even in the way that it treats racism as
a kind of stand in force in itself and
the way that the American Left broadly
treats racism of slavery for instance as
the original sin rather than then
original sin is the original sin there
is an interesting book that's coming out
pretty soon by Paul Kanger an excellent
writer and it's called the devil and
Karl Marx and I get to write the
foreword to that book which was a lot of
fun and it's about Marx's spiritual
history and the more you read of Marx
particularly as poetry you realize that
Marxism is a religion it's sort of an
anti religion but Marx is dealing
seriously with religious and spiritual
concepts and has a demonic presence
around him so many people who knew him
well used that phrase and so I think you
can certainly treat Marxism which is the
animating force of black lives matter as
a religion but as a legal matter look if
the courts are not willing to admit that
sex means sex and they're not willing to
admit that babies or babies and they're
not willing to say that abortionists
have to have the same credentials as
other medical professionals
unfortunately probably the deck is
stacked against you but good effort I
applaud it from Nick hi Michael
I am almost embarrassed to ask but I
need your advice on something
I've always felt like I had a secret
something I needed to hide from my
family and close friends I've known this
about myself for some time but was
afraid to act on my impulses I think
tulsi gabbard is a total smoke show
whose appearance is second only to
Aphrodite and truthfully after one beer
it would probably be a tie I'm tempted
to give in to my more primitive desires
and support her politically however
she's a total Lib what should I do
say profound question Nick do not give
in oh this is a tale as old as time my
friend
do not give in simply because you've
fallen a little bit gaga for an
admittedly very beautiful politician
particularly in comparison to her
colleagues who are generally speaking
physically less than beautiful now the
thing I will say for Tulsi she's got
some kind of interesting ideas she
breaks ranks with the Democrats on a
number of I don't even want to say
issues so much as premises or angles of
her worldview so if you want to fall in
politics with Tulsi Gabbard do so for
her vision of the world and for her
policy stances do not do so for her
physical beauty the physical beauty will
fade my friend but her voting record
will be forever from Erin hi Michael I
think Andrew Yang's idea of a four-day
workweek isn't good but how did the
five-day workweek come about how did it
happen that a six-day Work Week for
example wasn't the norm thanks great
question a lot of people give credit
here to the unions they always tell us
unions gave us the weekend that is not
true
do not give unions credit for that the
five-day workweek in the United States
predates Union demands for it by more
than 20 years
the first five-day workweek came about
in New England in 1908 that was and I
think was a cotton mill there and the
the purpose of that was to accommodate
Jews because Christian Sabbath is on
Sunday and with with a few exceptions
for various sects and Jews Sabbath is on
Saturday right Shabbat Friday night into
Saturday
so they got Saturday off to accommodate
the Jews thank the Jews for that one you
know Jews get a lot of they get a lot of
you know tough living in the in this
world and have for thousands of years
but you got to thank him for your
Saturday off then ironically speaking of
someone who didn't like the Jews very
much Henry Ford introduced the five-day
workweek and his factories in 1926 that
was a full three years before a clothing
union became the first union in America
to demand the five-day workweek so it
was capital
and the capitalists and Jews basically
who gave you the five-day workweek in
America and then the unions came around
later and took all the credit from
Patrick dear Michael all this talk of
police reform has got me wondering about
the purpose of bail is it merely a way
for richer people to avoid staying in
jail awaiting trial while allowing
police departments to get some extra
cash in their budget does it have a
history in British common law should we
continue to have it thanks for the
insight and historical perspective great
great question because now there is a
movement all around the country to
abolish bail and it's because people
either some some people useful idiots
don't understand bail and they just go
along with whatever the left tells them
to do and I think the left does
understand bail but they hate criminal
justice generally which is why they
don't just want to abolish me all they
want to abolish the police they they
literally want to abolish the police and
let criminals run wild so bail exists so
that criminals will show up at their
trial that you set bail not necessarily
by the crime but by the amount of money
that will induce a defendant to actually
show up at his trial because let's say I
get arrested for I don't know you some
probably probably the crime I'm going to
get arrested for in the future
democratic America is I'll like use too
much hairspray before my show and
they'll say that the CFC is like or
destroying the ozone or something and
they'll arrest me for that that or
something else and then if they say that
my bail is 10 bucks and I'll say alright
here's my ten bucks I'm gonna leave the
jail and I'm gonna run to Tijuana I'm
gonna get the hell outta Dodge so they
would have to set my bail higher because
I want to get the money back I want to I
want something that is keeping me in the
area and willing to show up for my trial
there there are some issues with bail
you know people will go out and borrow
money for bail and then they have this
kind of high interest loan and so there
are issues with it you could you could
talk about some aspects of bail reform
but I frankly I don't think now is the
time to do it because it's just like we
were talking about earlier the left is
not having a good-faith discussion here
they literally want to abolish criminal
justice and spring people
at least people of certain colors as
they've explicitly said now in many of
their protest demands from prison and so
I just don't think they're they're
having an honest conversation about
anything related to criminal justice and
we should not indulge their their false
premises from wisly hey Michael I have
recently been called a racist for
marrying a white woman I've also been
called a racist for preferring to live
in the USA over any other country is
having different preferences racist if I
chose a white woman over a brown or tan
woman or the USA over China am i racist
on social media many people are saying
racism is woven into each of us or we
all have racial biases even some saying
that we are born racists I believe in
God and I that I was created in His
image so as God is not a racist so then
I was not born a racist I'd love to hear
your thoughts yeah this is absurd I mean
I don't think anybody would ever attack
a Japanese man for marrying a Japanese
woman and call him a racist for doing
that I don't think anyone would ever
attack a Nigerian man for marrying a
Nigerian woman and call him a racist for
that but it has become fashionable in
some parts of the very far left to say
that a white person shouldn't marry a
white person because that would be
racist I mean the extreme version of
this you saw there was a transgendered
youtuber who said that if you're a man
straight man and you only want to date
women and you don't want to date men who
are dressed up as women then you're a
bigot you're transphobic I mean I think
those those arguments are fairly similar
I think if we're now politicizing even
just our personal attraction gosh
there's just nothing left that hasn't
been politicized the point you make
though is so important on on racism
itself and Christianity the only reason
that anybody thinks that racism is bad
is because of Christianity and Judaism
Judaism and you know the the prequel the
first the first book and then the second
book because man is made in the image of
God that's why we have human solidarity
that's why we have human dignity we come
from a common ancestor so if you
have that then you can't really explain
why racism is bad which is why we're the
only civilization in history that's ever
opposed racism another thing to mention
here on the race point that it just
occurred to me last night I was having a
cigar with Drew is Jesus who is a Jew is
is mixed right he's mixed race in the
sense that Ruth who is not a Jew she's a
Moabite woman who marries marries into
the Israelites is in his genealogy so
he's actually mixed and it's it's I like
this because it first of all I mean it
dismisses the social justice stuff
that's sorry you can you can push that
aside but it also pushes aside these
kind of cockamamie race theories that
basically privilege race is the most
important category in the world which
which it simply is not and you know a
fundamental truth will do that to you it
will push away lots of crazy ideologies
one more question from Jeremy dear
mostly peaceful podcaster I believe I
noticed a rifle of the scary black
variety during the video of the st.
Louis couple defending their home I was
told in the past that no one needs a
scary black rifle despite an angry mob
being a perfect situation for a scary
black rifle black rifle that's another
it's a term that also refers to that
that other awful term assault weapon or
the ar-15 given that gun and ammo sales
are up for the first time own own home
first-time gun owners do you think the
left will have a harder time convincing
people to vote anti-gun is the riding
enough to wake people up to at least the
self defense merits of the pro Second
Amendment stands thanks I have never
seen an issue cut across party lines so
well as the Second Amendment
obviously conservatives and Republicans
care about the Second Amendment much
more than Democrats but I know multiple
Democrats who are strongly pro-second
amendment some of them are one issue
voters which is why they end up voting
for Republicans even though they don't
really like Republicans and they prefer
Democrats I
you're gonna see Republicans get
demoralized in the next few months
because we're watching our country burn
around us and the Republican Party guys
like you know Ron Johnson and all these
other people are kind of giving in to
leftist premises and it's just terribly
dispiriting so I don't know that
necessarily it's going to give us a big
boost in November but one thing I do
know is that gun control legislation is
dead for the near future it is dead
nobody wants that there is no appetite
people want guns and I bet there are a
lot of pretty far left liberals who
secretly when nobody's looking
or sneaking out to the gun store right
now to protect themselves I think there
are a lot of people who are getting woke
on the reality of self-defense I mean
even the gun couple in Florida they are
Democrats they've donated to Democrats
they bend the knee to black lives matter
but they've got those guns and something
tells me they're going to be buying some
more guns in the future all right that's
our show
protect your your independence is best
you can you don't need to just arm
yourself with weapons you can arm
yourself with beers and hot dogs and
hamburgers this weekend I know that the
governing authorities the Democratic
demagogues and the squishy Republicans
are going to tell you not to have any
fun not to celebrate America the only
way you can go at is if you're gonna go
loot a Gucci store or something go steal
sneakers down the block but but other
than that you're not allowed to leave
your home I for one I'm gonna go to a
barbecue and it should be a lot of fun
happy 4th of July everybody I will see
you on Monday I'm Michael Knowles this
is the Michael Knowles show
[Music]
the Michael Nolt show is produced by Ben
Davies executive producer Jeremy Boren
supervising producers Mathis Glover and
Robert Stirling technical producer
Austin Stephens assistant director pavel
madoski editor and associate producer
danny D'Amico audio mixer robin fenders
hair and makeup nikka geneva production
assistant ryan love the michael knowles
show is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 20 20 if you prefer
facts over feelings aren't offended by
the brutal truth and you can still laugh
at the insanity filling our national
news cycle well tune in to the ben
shapiro show we'll get a whole lot of
that and much more see you there